NICK FARMER: So I'd like
to welcome everybody here
to another Talk at Google.
With us today, we have
Naren Shankar, Mark Fergus,
two of the show runners
for Syfy's "The Expanse."
NAREN SHANKAR: Hello.
MARK FERGUS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
NICK FARMER: So I'd just
like to jump in and ask you
guys, what do you think
makes "The Expanse"
different from other
science fiction shows?
NAREN SHANKAR: Hmm,
well, the low quality
of the writing on which
is was based, obviously.
No, I think everybody had the
same reaction to the material
when we read it.
It's a different look at space.
It is about the small people.
It's not about the
admirals, and the people
who are in charge of starships.
It is a more intimate, it's
a more boots on the ground
version of it.
You should--
MARK FERGUS: Yeah,
I think, again, we
had all responded to the
same things in the novels,
but we felt like Syfy
the genre had always
skipped over the first couple
of years of colonization.
What we consider the real
interesting story is how did we
claw our way off the planet?
How do did get out to the
Moon, Mars, the solar system,
bringing all our
daemons with us,
all our cultural
baggage, everything,
and show how we forge the way
to "Star Trek" and "Galactica"
and all these other
classic shows,
where technology was sorted out,
and aliens had been contacted,
and we were dealing with them.
The first couple of centuries,
we kept thinking of it
as the railroads coming
to America's story, where
the landscape changed
because of technology,
and let's just
bring that to space.
That was the
fascinating story to us,
and nobody had told it
particularly well until we read
"The Expanse" books, and we were
like, this is the show we've
always wanted to see.
Let's go make that
show, as opposed
to thousands of other properties
that were really cool too,
but this is a story that
we've been dying to see.
NAREN SHANKAR: It was
also unique in that space
was a character in the show.
All of the things that
people ignore usually,
things like gravity,
and oxygen, and air,
and the things that make
space such an inhospitable
environment for
human life, those
are whisked away in most
shows, with transporter beams
and artificial gravity
plating, and the fact that you
can have instantaneous
communication anywhere
across the galaxy.
This show was different.
It allowed us to have space
become a real character
dramatically in the series,
and we tried to exploit that.
MARK FERGUS: And just
following up on that,
space battle becomes
hard and difficult,
the way old ship battle used
to be, submarine battle.
It was slow.
It was anticipatory.
It was like playing chess rather
than vast and instantaneous
distances, are vast
like crossing an ocean.
Communication takes--
you call someone on Mars,
and it takes a half
hour to get a response.
And so we're back to pre-cell
phone kind of communication,
not where battles--
and things have
to happen where by the
time you say something
to the field of a battle,
by the time it reaches you
and you get a message
back, the battle's over.
So you have to think in
an entirely different way.
And yes, space is a character.
It's vast.
It's huge.
The speed of light is
only the speed of light.
Only, there's limitations that
we put back on storytelling
that most sci-fi
says, oh, don't worry.
Technology solved all that.
The engine is dead.
Everyone's still in gravity?
Don't ask why?
It's just part of the deal.
And we're like, no.
If you stop moving, and
your thrust is gone,
you're going to
start floating up.
And that becomes a
really cool thing
that we weave into the
story that we get to use,
instead of just
brushing over it.
And the books are full
of that kind of thing.
I think that's what
we responded to.
That's a space story
we haven't seen before.
NICK FARMER: And so what's it
from a creative perspective
that you're writing
these things?
What are the challenges
that you've come up with?
NAREN SHANKAR: So many.
It's a very ambitious show.
I mean, first of all, all
these things like zero gravity,
they're traditionally
not often done,
and the books are full of them.
It's got a very big scope.
It's got a lot of
different characters.
The show was originally sold
really as "Game of Thrones"
in space, and it has
that quality to it.
And that's certainly something
that we've tried to play,
but it means you've got to
build a lot of big sets.
You've got to create
these environments.
You've got to build space ships.
You've got a tremendous
amount of visual effects work.
It is as complex a show as
I've ever been involved in.
MARK FERGUS: And then we had
talked about it earlier too.
There's things that
are on the page,
like Belters are tall and
light because reduced gravity
changes the cartilage,
changes the bone structure,
changes the physicality,
which we love,
because it's
essentially technology
leads to us going
out into space.
And as a result of that,
a new race of humans
is created by environment.
They're still human, and yet
they're completely different.
They can never go
back to full G planets
and live, because their
bodies have grown up.
Production-wise,
how are you going
to get hundreds,
thousands of seven
foot tall, very skinny
great actors as well?
NAREN SHANKAR: The answer,
of course, is money.
MARK FERGUS: Right.
So in the absence
of that, we decided
to create the full spectrum of--
this was an adaptation problem.
On the page it's easy
to say everybody looks
like this on the screen.
Unless we're an
animated film, we
have to do this in a smart way.
So it ended up becoming a
great opportunity to say,
yes, there are extreme
belters with the full range
of physicality.
In essence, the poorer you
were, the more difficult
your economic upbringing,
you're on zero G ships,
you're way out in the system.
The more difficult your
economic situation is,
the more Belter you
would be, because you'd
be in harder conditions.
And we did the full spectrum,
so you could have race traitors.
You could have people
hiding, pretending
they're an Earther, when
they're actually a Belter.
You can have extreme Belters,
who are looked down on.
You have Earthers
slumming it, wanting
to pretend they're Belters.
You have a whole
range of stuff now.
We can put that in
the story as opposed
to that monolithic kind
of-- Ty had always called it
the thing of a lot of sci-fi.
A race of people looks the same.
They speak the same.
They have the same
attitude about everything.
They're a race, and that
wouldn't-- I feel that for this
show, that would have gotten
boring really quickly.
So I'm glad that we
had the constraint,
because it came to, I think,
a cooler solution, definitely.
NICK FARMER: So for
those who may not know,
Ty Franck and Daniel
Abraham, the authors
who combine to make the
pen name James SA Corey,
have an unprecedented
level of participation
in the creation of the show.
And what's that like for you,
to work with the authors,
to have them with
you at all times?
NAREN SHANKAR: When I was
brought onto the show,
and Mark and his writing
partner Hawk Ostby,
they wrote the pilot, and
I was brought in later,
after it was sold to Syfy.
And I was told, you start
the show, and here we go.
I'm going to go do the series.
And by the way, the two
writers who wrote the book
are going to be in the room.
And I was, are you sure
that's a really good idea?
Because usually authors can
be very precious with what
they've written.
They don't want to
change anything.
But very quickly we
found that Ty and Daniel
were incredibly open to
truly adapting the material
to a different medium.
It's like things that they
do in the book would not
have lent themselves
to the story the way
we're portraying it
dramatically on television.
The first book is
two characters.
It's told from two perspectives.
The chapters alternate
between them.
We had to bring in other
elements to the show,
and so they were
incredibly open to it,
and we actually started
pulling in material
that they had written.
They had written novellas
to support the material,
and we started bringing those
in, characters from books
further along in the series.
And what it enabled us to do
was truly adapt the material.
It's a slightly
different thing, but it's
remained incredibly true
to the source material
all along the way.
And with Ty and Daniel there,
we don't break anything.
There have been times when we'll
go, oh, what if we do this,
and they're like, well, you're
going to totally ruin book 5.
And we're like, OK, we
won't do that, then.
And so we figure out a
different way around it.
And also at times, we'll
be looking for, well, gee,
can we do something in this
episode that illuminates
a part of Belter culture?
It's like, if only
we had something,
and Ty will say, well, what if
you did this thing that I've
got three books down the line?
We're like, that's perfect.
Let's put that in.
And so they allow us
to stay on target.
They exploit the scope of the
world that they've created,
and we're just the
beneficiaries of that.
MARK FERGUS: Yeah.
NICK FARMER: Just a
light hearted question.
If you were to pick a
faction for yourselves,
would you be Earthers,
Martians, or Belters?
MARK FERGUS: I think the Belters
are really what the books are
about, ultimately.
I feel like definitely,
because that's
where all the drama is
going on, and that's
where all of the
passion in the story is.
They're these scattered
tribes of people flung out
of into the solar system,
trying to figure out
some identity for themselves,
to collect together,
to stay as tribes, to survive
out there in a new environment.
You've got the
empires, fighting over
who's going to be the top dog,
and of course, the Belters
are at the shit end
of that, usually.
The people who built the
apparatus for the empires
to exist out in the
solar system then become
exiles out in space,
and they're forgotten.
And that's where all the
really cool grist is,
I think, in this story.
And I think they're
also the coolest
and the most interesting
people in the story.
The Earth is the old the
new empire, old, empire
thing, which I think
human behavior seems
to always go that way, anyway.
So one of the things we
loved about the stories too,
it's just the endless
cycle of rising and falling
and building, and
oppressed class, empire,
leading to crusty old empire
that falls into the sea.
The other one becomes
the crusty old--
it's just the way we're wired,
and the story in a larger
sense, what happens?
Is there any way
out of that cycle?
Is there any technological
or spiritual way
out of that endless cycle?
So to make a short answer to
the question, it's Belters.
I think I wandered from
the-- which I will do.
Just got to go, get
back, get back, get back.
NAREN SHANKAR: As a
humorless technologist,
I'd probably be a Martian.
I've definitely
noticed from the fans
that even though the
Martians haven't appeared
so much in season
one, a lot of people
really like the idea of
having the sleek ships
and the big guns.
MARK FERGUS: They
got the cool stuff.
NAREN SHANKAR: They do.
They have the cool stuff.
MARK FERGUS: Belters rocks.
NICK FARMER: Yeah,
well, that works too
under the right circumstances.
MARK FERGUS: That's right.
And cargo containers
with engines.
NAREN SHANKAR: Exactly.
Spoiler alert.
NICK FARMER: I'm a little
partial to the Belters myself.
MARK FERGUS: Understandably.
You made the language.
NICK FARMER: Yeah, I mean, it's
because I'm over six feet tall.
MARK FERGUS: You made
the language too.
That's true.
NICK FARMER: So you have a PhD
in physics and engineering.
Can you tell us a
little about your story,
going from that to Hollywood?
NAREN SHANKAR: I had
an odd trajectory.
I started as a humanities
student in medieval studies.
NICK FARMER: Gasp in Google.
NAREN SHANKAR: Yeah, I know.
Medieval studies,
French literature, but I
had always loved
science and mathematics.
And I think in my
sophomore year,
I realized that the
chance of actually getting
a job with the degrees
that I was looking at
were probably quite slim.
So I transferred
into engineering.
And it's also cultural.
First generation Indian is like
doctor, lawyer, businessman,
engineer.
That's what you've got to do.
And so I transferred into
engineering, and I stayed.
And I stayed all the
way through to my PhD.
But as I was finishing
my dissertation,
I started-- I mean, the things
that I loved were history,
and so I started taking
more and more courses
in the liberal arts college.
And I think it just
got to the point
where I had that moment
where I was coming out.
I was taking a
course in the history
of American foreign
policy taught
by this amazing
professor at Cornell.
And I came out of this terrific
lecture about Aaron Burr,
and I was walking
back to my lab.
And I could see it down
at the end of the street,
and I was like, oh my god.
I can't do this anymore.
And it was not I didn't
love engineering.
I did it.
It was I felt myself becoming
more and more of a specialist
in a smaller and smaller
corner of the universe,
and that just wasn't
my personality.
And I finished the dissertation,
and I told my parents
that I was going to go to
Los Angeles and be a writer.
And to their credit, my
parents were adorable.
They were very supportive.
And I started
college really young,
and so they figured I had
a couple years to burn.
And I drove, and I'd come to
my senses and get a real job.
But as I was driving
away 10 years later,
my mother told me, as soon
as my car went out of sight,
she burst into tears.
But it worked out OK.
It worked out OK.
That's the long story.
NICK FARMER: I've
heard a story that tied
into why you were graduating
from college young,
a you were little bit ahead,
and you had a briefcase.
NAREN SHANKAR: God damn it, Ty.
Yes.
Yes, I own this story.
When I was in like sixth
grade, my parents, who
were immigrants,
they thought it would
be awesome to give their son
a briefcase to take to school.
And like a good son,
I took it to school
for like the next four years.
And let me tell you, that was
a chick magnet, a briefcase.
No, I had a good friend,
who actually every day we
would come back from school,
he would kick the shit out
of the briefcase.
And in my sophomore year of
high school, it exploded.
Almost everything went
all over the snow,
and I was just done
with the briefcase.
NICK FARMER: No more briefcases?
NAREN SHANKAR: No
more briefcases.
MARK FERGUS: That's [INAUDIBLE]
I'm just picturing it.
NAREN SHANKAR: It was so sad.
NICK FARMER: Well,
I mean, I wonder
if any of those people
who tormented you
are watching your shows.
I mean, you probably
have some fans who
don't even make the connection.
NAREN SHANKAR: Yeah,
screw those guys.
I hope they are.
NICK FARMER: So I'd like
to give everybody time
to think about their questions.
We're setting up
a mic over here.
And make sure that
when you line up
that you are lined
up behind each other.
I'm a linguist,
and I can't talk.
NAREN SHANKAR: I
was going to say.
NICK FARMER: I know.
Well, this is why you guys
had to hire a voice coach,
and you couldn't just have
me work with the actors.
I mean, I would go in
there, and I would just
mess up my own language.
NAREN SHANKAR: That was fun.
Mark did a lot of that
with the voice acting
and the coaching of the Belters.
MARK FERGUS: Yeah, well, I
worked for an entire year
on a show, where Nick
created an entire language
for the Belters.
And we probably would have
worked countless hours.
I literally met him for the
first time two days ago,
and spoke to him
for the first time,
even though we did
a show together.
But yeah, it would be
lines going to Nick.
He would create the language,
then it would come back.
We would bring them to our
dialect coach, essentially.
He would teach people how
to act and say and inflect
in a completely created language
with a very specific accent.
And some actors dove into that.
Other actors were terrified
to not only learn your lines
and feel it, and swim in
it, and get all the subtext,
but also learn a new
language and a new accent
now, and be ready tomorrow.
It was a little frightening.
NAREN SHANKAR: It was a
great thing in the show too.
Because one of the
things in the book
was that humanity had
gone out into the Belt.
It wasn't just white Americans
going out into space.
It was the Russians, the
Chinese, the Indians.
And so the Belt was
this polyglot mix
of different cultures
and language styles
and little pieces of them.
And the Martians had different
strains in their language
as well.
And it's just been a
really interesting thing,
because when you start
feeling those little threads,
you start feeling
those little bits
and pieces of human culture
in this different place,
it was just a unique thing in
the show that I really like.
I really loved that.
MARK FERGUS: It was cool.
I don't know who-- was
it Ty's or your analogy
of the Mediterranean
fishing village.
Space is just considered
all these different factions
coming to work in space, and
coming, going, transporting.
And what happens to
language and culture
over hundreds of years in that
kind of transitory environment?
And that's where the
language came from.
And it was great,
because we could
do anything we wanted
with it, but we
wanted to stick to
structure and rules,
so it didn't feel like bull.
It felt like a real language
with a history and a structure.
NAREN SHANKAR:
Even the gestures.
MARK FERGUS: Yeah.
NAREN SHANKAR: It's described
as a gestural language,
and Ty and Daniel are saying
that it was derived from people
in space suits who spoke
different languages not being
able to talk to one another.
So they adopted some very broad
signaling, gestural signaling,
with their hands so they could
look at each other in space
and understand it.
And over time, that
concept had boiled
down into a very expressive
hand gestures along with Belter.
And so that was
part of it as well,
and it's lovely when you
can pull details like that
into a show, because it
just grounds the world.
It makes it all feel very real.
MARK FERGUS: So
thank you for that.
AUDIENCE: So you touched
on this a little bit,
talking about the
Belters height and stuff
and having to change a
little bit from the books.
But I had a question about
doing practical effects
for the low gravity
areas, like Ceres.
Because you have the drones
flying around in the shots.
And I haven't finished
the show, so maybe there's
something like this in a later
episode, but showing somebody.
Picking up something
impractically heavy,
or having an
occasional object not
fall as fast as
you would expect,
or anything like
that, because it's
a little offputting
for them to be
talking about how it's
gravity, and then everything's
like heavy.
MARK FERGUS: Yeah,
we had to choose.
I think we had to create-- We
had talked about this earlier,
as well.
Ceres is a third G
environment, and it
would affect lots of
areas of behavior,
how Earthers would walk and
be too ahead of themselves.
They'd be jumping all the
time, objects falling.
I think what we tried
to do is tell the story,
make sure that people understood
this is not normal gravity.
But then don't let it get
in the way of every scene.
Otherwise, you just
can't tell the story.
And so we put things like
a bird flapping its wings.
AUDIENCE: The budget, I realize
you can't put everybody on a--
NAREN SHANKAR: I'm sorry.
What was that?
AUDIENCE: I was going
to say, I realize
you don't have the budget
to film every episode
on the vomit comet.
MARK FERGUS: No, even
so, it would be--
NAREN SHANKAR: When
we talked about it,
it was ultimately those things
would get normalized out
very quickly, and Ceres would
be like, even though everything
was maybe not as heavy
as a similar object would
be on Earth, relative
to Ceres, everything
would be accounted for.
So the number of times that you
can actually show differences
were actually fairly small,
because it's how do you
show weight on television?
It's very tough.
So what we did is we
picked a couple of things.
Coriolis is one of them,
in that in different parts
of the station, if you pour
a fluid, the deflection
of the fluid relative to
where you were in the station
and the spin gravity
causes it to deflect.
So you see that when Miller is
pouring from his scotch bottle.
Instead of going like this, it
goes like that into the glass.
When you see a bird, the sparrow
that he flips a little peanut
to or whatever on his
balcony, that bird
was meticulously animated so
that the beating of the wings
is a little bit different
than it would be on Earth.
So the smaller
moments where you can
establish a different gravity
situation were more effective.
We tried, and one thing
we completely failed
at doing-- there
are two things we
failed at doing
in the pilot, was
a bicycle stunt-- oh my god.
What a nightmare--
In the pilot to try
to show a reduced gravity flip.
It was misconceived.
The director hated it.
We made him shoot it.
We spent half a
fucking day-- sorry.
And a day--
MARK FERGUS: No,
that's worth it.
NAREN SHANKAR: And we cut it
out of the pilot entirely.
MARK FERGUS: It
just didn't work.
NAREN SHANKAR:
And the other one,
we had one scene that we
could never make work,
because we all thought
it was comical.
It was Miller has an
Earth partner who's come
to Ceres for the first time.
And we thought it would
be interesting if there's
a chase, to do a chase.
And the Earth guy,
because he hasn't quite
acclimated to Ceres, he runs
so hard that he goes up.
Because he's much stronger, he's
does a Superman kind of a jump.
And we wrote it into the
script a couple times,
and the director was
just going, guys, it's
going to look stupid.
MARK FERGUS: That's the thing.
If it doesn't feel
like part of the show,
it will just look like
the guy's an idiot.
And the bike trick looked like
a stupid bike trick on Earth,
really.
NAREN SHANKAR: In that
case, we were idiots.
MARK FERGUS: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But the bird, you see
the wings flapping
a third of the amount of time,
and the bird hovering aloft.
It's one way, and Coriolis.
There's a few things
that actually landed,
and hopefully we
paint enough points
that you realize the
whole environment.
But use ones that are
visual and distinctive.
NAREN SHANKAR: One that
worked really well,
this is towards the
end of the season,
is one of our
characters, they're
trying to get out of the
station, an asteroid station.
They're not sure which
direction they're going.
And so she takes a little bit
of dust, and she drops it.
And by the way it spins,
she understands which way
they're moving, spinward or
anti-spinward on the station.
And so she's able to
actually understand
where she is relative to that.
And it's not
commented on at all.
I mean, it just exists
there, and so it's
an interesting moment.
AUDIENCE: So I realize
that you don't really
have a chance to know
how far out the show is
going to keep going.
NAREN SHANKAR: Forever.
AUDIENCE: Well,
that would be great,
because I'm really enjoying it.
But I'm curious.
How do you structure
things in terms
of like, this is
where we're at, this
is where the books are
going, this is where we want
to end the season, which may
or may not coincide directly
with the end of the book, and
thinking like how far ahead do
you think on that stuff?
I know you've been picked
up for the second season,
and the books, obviously,
are going on for a while,
and there's more books planned.
And so I'm really curious how
the structure of the TV seasons
and the structure of the books
are combined in a show running
sense.
MARK FERGUS: I mean,
we're just going
with our gut in terms
of each season needs
to be a complete experience, a
complete story, like a 10 hour,
13 hour movie with
its own structure.
Then we fit that into a
larger structure of seasons.
I think we're just
going toward what
is the next big
evolution of the story.
It doesn't always
coincide with the books,
because we don't have
to it's crazy to go
as fast as the books.
To cram it in, we'd be losing
so much great material.
So one of the things we had to
learn, Hawk and I, from Naren
is slow down.
Stop burning through the story.
Stop trying to get to a fixed
point because the book did.
And you're going to have to
blow past all this amazing stuff
to get to a point.
So I think we've
adjusted our pace
to learn to tell the story,
bring the novellas in, bring
characters in.
Let the thing evolve
at its own pace,
and each big chunk of
it, if we're lucky enough
to keep going, will just
find the next great turning
point and the next great--
The first season, we
would have ideally loved
to get through the first book.
It wasn't feasible
for a lot of reasons,
and not even advisable.
So we picked a great
turning point of the book
to be the season end,
and we could get there
at a pace that was appropriate.
So it's a hard
question to answer,
but every block needs
to feel like-- I always
think of it as to feel like its
own contained, awesome season.
Whether or not you
get a next one,
you end on a really
amazing point
that feels like the
characters have evolved.
The story has evolved.
We've opened up the
universe that much more,
and then hopefully, we'll be
back to fill in more stuff.
NAREN SHANKAR: In both
season 1 and season 2,
we started the year by a few
weeks of just discussion,
really, about what that very
broad structure of the show
was.
And season one was 10 episode.
Season 2 is going to be 13.
You have these books that
have a really strong, well
delineated plot framework.
And so there's probably
several points in book one
that we could have chosen
to end the season at.
We picked one in particular,
and the same thing
is happening as we're
going into book 2.
But what you get is,
once you understand what
the pace of the show is, once
you get a broad idea of where
you want to go, it
starts to lay down,
and you start to
see episodically
what the events are.
And yeah, we're very
tightly serialized,
so you can watch the
whole thing through,
and it's telling you a story.
But if you watch the
individual episodes,
there's usually some sense of
completeness, episodically.
And so those first few
weeks of the season
is where you really
talk that stuff through,
and pretty quickly, you get
to an understanding of how
the season wants
to lay itself down,
and the story that
you want to tell.
It's usually there.
You just have to find it.
And I think that when
we come into the season,
somebody will say, well, hey,
what if we ended it here?
And everybody's like, that's
a great place to end it,
and just seems very natural.
And so I think that's at
least our plan going forward
to continue that.
AUDIENCE: I thought
where you chose
to end the first season
a good stopping point.
NAREN SHANKAR: Nice.
All right.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: That worked well,
as far as I was concerned.
NAREN SHANKAR: We
had some arguments
with the network about that.
NICK FARMER: The
funny thing is, when
I got the ebook for "Leviathan
Wakes," the first book, it came
packaged with one of
Daniel's other books,
from a fantasy series.
And so I knew that at some
point that this book was not
900 pages long,
so it had to end,
but I didn't know quite where
it was in the page count.
And actually, as
I was reading it,
I thought, OK, pretty soon
the Daniel's fantasy book
is about to start.
And then I'm like, oh wait, no.
There's a much longer--
NAREN SHANKAR: There's a a
bunch of spots like that.
NICK FARMER:
There's a coda here.
AUDIENCE: A couple of things.
One is I was really impressed
with the casualness with which
Miller, particularly, operated
his various bits of media
technology.
I mean, it was a
steadied casualness.
I haven't really seen that
in a sci-fi show before.
The other, two things.
One is a I noticed a lot
of the sci-fi set dressing
has elements of contemporary
technology in it,
flat screens and so forth.
And I'm wondering,
is that just part
of the hurdle to
get a show done,
that you don't try to do one off
special versions of everything?
Well, that'll be
fine for this milieu,
or if it was more of
an aesthetic choice.
And the other question, which
is a little more involved
is, right now, you guys are
funded by a large television
network, but you
were saying you'd
like to have this go on forever,
but you're living and dying
at the whim of Syfy or
some other network type
organization.
Do you see a show of
this kind of scope
becoming something
that could be produced
as an internet only
show over time?
NAREN SHANKAR:
Internet only show?
You mean like a Netflix show?
AUDIENCE: Like a fan-funded.
For example--
NAREN SHANKAR: Fan-funded?
That's a lot of fans.
AUDIENCE: I purchased
your show directly off
of, whatever, Amazon, right?
Don't have to watch commercials.
I've got I've got a little
bit more money than free time,
so I do it that way.
And I'm wondering if you see
that kind of thing happening
enough to where the economics
would work out that you could
produce without this sort
of large advertiser-driven
business.
NAREN SHANKAR: If
somebody asked me
that question outside
of this place,
I would say go ask Google.
Because I suspect you have
far better metrics on that
than I do.
AUDIENCE: I'm asking
for your gut, man.
NAREN SHANKAR: I mean,
it's a good question.
The business is going over the
top in so many different ways.
I mean, Netflix
has clearly shown
that there's a
subscriber-driven basis
to make high quality
entertainment.
So fan-funding is
another thing entirely.
I don't know what the most you
know expensive fan-funded--
AUDIENCE: Maybe that was
a poor choice of words,
but consumer-funded would
be another way of saying it.
I want to watch, so
I'll pay you some money.
NAREN SHANKAR: Listen, you're
asking a really interesting
question.
It's a very interesting model.
And I think that
probably it's partially
dependent on discovery
and targeting.
Because I think that
for this type of show,
if the fans were
given that option,
and you were able to
reach all of them,
could each person put
$2.50 in an episode?
You're buying a latte
at Starbucks every day
to watch that.
The answer is probably, yes.
But can you get can you drive
that kind of money to the show?
That's another
question entirely.
I don't know.
With regard to the stuff,
the props and stuff?
AUDIENCE: The
actual set dressing.
MARK FERGUS: I think
it's a bit of both.
NAREN SHANKAR:
It's a bit of both.
MARK FERGUS: I mean, to
create these one off objects
is incredibly expensive and
incredibly time consuming.
So some of it had to be
done a little more broad,
because you had so much
of that everywhere.
But also, I think
aesthetically--
NAREN SHANKAR: We're
a little retro too.
We're a little retro.
That's aesthetic.
MARK FERGUS: Yeah, absolutely.
And I think the idea
that to make a statement
about technology, that's why
we bashed up Miller's screen
to have a big in the middle.
NAREN SHANKAR: A
nice crack in it.
MARK FERGUS: There's
only two, technology
rises and eats us story,
or technology saves us.
Tech in sci-fi is
always one of the two.
It's a paradise, or it rises
up and robots kill us all.
And what I loved about the
books, they're like, who cares?
Technology is there.
It's awesome.
It's in the background.
Human behavior is still--
it didn't save us.
It didn't eat us.
It's there, and it didn't
really solve our problems.
There's tons of advanced
tech in these books.
It's mentioned when
it's interesting,
or when it matters to the story.
And weirdly, it feels
like they've ignored it,
and it's just no.
They put it in its place, which
is it's in the background.
Who cares?
And I love that about the
books, that it's not about will
technology destroy us?
Will it save us?
It's kind of neither.
We're still people.
We're still out there,
fumbling around trying
to figure out the human
condition kind of crap.
And technology is
there, and it exists.
And the way you would always
tell them your car analogy.
NAREN SHANKAR: I stole
that analogy from Ty.
MARK FERGUS: Well, you
don't get in your car,
and say, what an amazing
transportation apparatus
this is.
NAREN SHANKAR: I am fan of the
internal combustion engine.
Nobody says this.
MARK FERGUS: And they put
tech in the books on that par.
There's amazing medical
advancements in the books.
There's amazing robotics, AI.
Everything, it's just
so in the background,
because it's just part
of normal life now.
So to make the stories about
that would kill what's--
NAREN SHANKAR: There's
a show I won't name,
it was a broadcast show, but
it had a whole scene where
it was about a drone that
took your garbage out
from your kitchen
to the driveway.
It was so ridiculous.
And that was the whole scene.
Technology in our world has
gone into the background.
And you made the comments
about Miller gesturing
and how fluid it was.
What we told the actors
was, do whatever you want.
Because the idea was
that the technology
would respond to you.
You don't have to make
a specific gesture,
that things are
listening to you,
and watching you, and
understanding you in context.
So there's this beautiful
scene in episode 5,
where Miller's
manipulating a star map,
and it's really gorgeous.
Thomas Jane did
whatever he wanted to.
He was doing deliberate
things, but then our animators
animated to it.
And nothing was choreographed.
He simply just did
what he felt was right.
He understood the
moments in the script,
because they were scripted.
But the actual visual effect was
created to match his movement,
and that's why it
feels very real.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
Thanks a lot for
coming out today.
Naren, if it makes
you feel any better,
I didn't have a
briefcase, but I had
one of those rolling backpacks.
NAREN SHANKAR: Right, you
know what I'm talking about.
AUDIENCE: I used to get
the crap beat out of me.
NAREN SHANKAR: See, I'm a little
older, so I didn't have that.
MARK FERGUS: Technology.
NAREN SHANKAR: No, no wheels
then, not for the children.
AUDIENCE: Guys, I have a
question more on the writing
side.
I'm curious to hear from
you how much actors had
an influence on the writings.
NAREN SHANKAR: As
little as possible.
AUDIENCE: One can hope.
But I mean, obviously
there's a character arc
you have to follow, a story
arc for every character,
and the books give you
guidance, but after seeing
what the actors could
do, how much did that
influence your writing,
based on their own qualities
and limitations?
MARK FERGUS: I mean, certainly
once the actors start
to own the character, and you
get tuned to their rhythm,
and you see the way they're
burrowing in, what they resist,
what really unlocks
their inner greatness,
you start to see
what works for them.
Thomas Jane, for example,
he's a very emotional actor,
but he plays it
with the emotions
bubbling under the surface.
If you give him an
opportunity for that,
he sinks his teeth into a scene.
If you want him to
play overtly emotional,
and weepy, and over-the-top,
that shuts him down,
because it doesn't really
tap into what he's great at.
So it's our job not to
change the story based
on everybody's ideas,
because then you have chaos,
but to listen to what's
working, to really
start shaping it for that
actor, and then listening.
They start to have
ownership over these people,
and they start saying,
hey, you know what?
I'm a little uncomfortable
with this moment or whatever.
And then make them
feel safe to be
able to bring their
thoughts and ideas
and keep it open like that.
So it ended up
working both ways,
but we try to really
commit to story choices.
But then the texture
of it, the way into it
align, I think we've been really
happy the more it engages them,
the more we want
to hear from them.
And it's been a really
great relationship.
NAREN SHANKAR: We
also, in our process,
the way we develop the season,
we have a lot of material
at the script stage
going into a season.
And so the actors get big
chunks of material at a time,
and when they are
able to read it,
when they see it stretched out
over a story arc or a character
arc over several
episodes, I think
it gives them a
lot of confidence
that the people who are
writing the material
know where they're going.
And actors get
concerned when they
feel like things are
happening at random
or for no reason, or
capriciously, or arbitrarily.
That's when they get weird.
But when they see that the
story is actually happening,
and there's meaning
behind what they're doing,
then they get comfortable.
And that's been our experience.
They will chime in.
Things get shaded a
little differently.
There's an interpretation
that maybe we
didn't see that we're
certainly happy to dig into.
But by and large, they've
stayed on the page.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks guys.
AUDIENCE: So I really
enjoyed the first season,
and I got a ton of
questions, but I
think I narrowed it to two.
One of them is about whole
treatment of sound in space.
I'm just curious how
you guys feel about it,
because right now, we're
seeing a lot of people
going for the soundless effect.
And I appreciate both
versions in the right context,
but I was just wonder
whether you guys
had thoughts about that.
NAREN SHANKAR: I
should tell this story.
We talked about that.
MARK FERGUS: Let's
put it this way.
This has been a very
important decision
and an important discussion,
so it was not made--
NAREN SHANKAR: No, it
was not made lightly.
A couple of things.
Every show has done things
a little bit differently.
"Galactica," for example,
they took a muffled soundscape
in space, and so
they crunched things
down a little bit sonically.
It was interesting.
When we started developing
the sound design for the show,
we had some guys who
were like, we really
want to use these
contact mics on things,
and they were hitting
things, because they
wanted it to sound like the
astronauts in their suits
on the ISS.
Oh, isn't that going to be
really neat and everything?
And so they did
all of this work,
and they put these
sounds in the show.
And we're watching it,
and we go that sucks.
It's like you have people
walking down a creepy corridor,
and you're hearing something
that goes dun, dun, dun.
It just sounds like they're
stepping on plastic.
And so there's no tension.
There was no scare.
And so even though
that was the real sound
of what was happening
and probably
what would be conducted
through your spacesuit
when you're hitting something
in a vacuum, it didn't matter.
What it was doing
was dramatically
it was ruining the
goddamn moment.
And so what happened
was we made the decision
to go big, to go gut wrenching,
and things that are moving fast
and have a tremendous
amount of mass,
make them feel big and
heavy, and fast and scary.
It's an aesthetic choice.
I mean, we would
sit in the mixes,
and I'd be going scare
the shit out of me!
It's like, turn the thing up.
And it's half of
what you perceive
as entertainment is sound.
it's an incredibly, incredibly
important element to it.
And they've done tests
where they'll show audiences
the exact same film.
And one version is a crappy
mix, and the second version
is an amazing mix.
And the perception
from the audience
is that the one with a good
mix has a better picture.
It's an amazing thing.
It's just how we
perceive the world.
So the story I like to
tell is that years ago, I
was doing a show called
"The Outer Limits,"
and it was an anthology
science fiction show.
And we were filming in a cave.
I mean, it was like we
were doing a cave set,
and there's lights.
And I was going, oh my god.
What are these
lights coming from?
It's in the cave.
This is dark.
And the DP on the show
told me this story
about an old movie, the
'50s, James Mason, "Journey
to the Center of the Earth."
The director had a breakdown
during the filming,
because he suddenly
realized, oh my god.
We're inside the Earth.
Where is the light coming from?
And he's freaking out.
And the DP goes, it's
coming from the same place
as the music.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK FERGUS: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: I like it.
Cool.
MARK FERGUS: Sound, I
think sound is the language
of the subconscious, the heart.
It is so much more primal than
visual and any other element
that we've got going.
And to leave that off the
palette to tell your story,
it's just not realistic,
and it's one of those things
you have to let go, because
we're telling a story here,
and we're taking so
many of our colors away.
And the subconscious stuff
that makes you see differently
because you're hearing
differently, to lose that
is hobbling everything
we're trying to do.
So you've just got
to say screw it.
NICK FARMER: And just to insert
a comment on that, certainly
with the language
part, there's nothing
so viscerally foreign
as hearing a language
that you don't understand.
And that's because there's
just some parts of your brain
that are so keyed into that.
MARK FERGUS: It's why
music can wreck you.
A great song or a song
that brings you back
to your childhood,
or a song that
hits the right-- it
holds, and then it lets
go, and you feel like
you're going to weep.
No one can figure that out.
NAREN SHANKAR: It's the lizard
part of your brain, honestly.
MARK FERGUS: You've got
to grab every bit of that.
And in a box that
we have 42 minutes
to tell a story with
all these elements,
sound is so, so important.
I appreciate the question,
because it's one of those ones
that we really did not--
we're a science-based show.
We tried--
NAREN SHANKAR: We
really did try.
AUDIENCE: You guys got
a lot of good details.
MARK FERGUS: That one, screw it.
NAREN SHANKAR: It sucked so bad.
It was so bad.
AUDIENCE: I liked
it, though, thanks.
The second question
is, between how
you have a book series going
on and you have a television
series, you've got these
two separate things.
And book, television often
will take some liberties
from the books, but
is there any moment
where you feel like, I just
want to take the lead now.
Do you ever think it catches up?
Kind of like the
Marvel universe,
how the movies are now
influencing the comics more.
I know the authors may
have rights to all this,
but do you ever think,
I got an idea for this,
how it should go?
NAREN SHANKAR: I don't know.
I think that the problem
is when you take it out
of the imagination and
you put it on the film,
you're stuck with those faces.
You're stuck with that world.
And I mean, that's really a
question for Ty and Daniel,
because they're the ones
who are writing the books.
MARK FERGUS: We're not going
to catch up any time soon.
NAREN SHANKAR: No, we're
not going to catch up,
but it's an
interesting question.
You need to send it to them.
Are they being influenced on
the writing side novelistically
by what they're seeing
in the television show?
And I don't know
what the answer is.
Because we're
following their lead,
and we're trying not
to change too much.
We're trying to
stay real faithful
and make it a real,
true adaptation of what
they've written.
But I think it may be inevitable
to have some cross talk.
MARK FERGUS: I wonder if just
the visuals of the actors
we've chosen who really
own-- Naomi Nagata was very
specifically
described in the book,
and our actress Dominique played
exactly what's on the page,
except she put all the pain
inside, instead of wearing it
on her sleeve, and the
character in the book more
wore her-- she would shut down.
She would hide, and
Dominique doesn't do that.
But you can tell there's a ton
of pain and anxiety, and joy,
and everything else
going on underneath,
but she lets it out in
a tough kind of way.
And I don't know
how you can not get
infected with her version of the
character writing her forward.
I don't know if those
guys get tainted by that,
or were affected by that.
But we'll certainly have
to read the new books
and see if we're
having any effect.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
NICK FARMER: So we have time
for one last quick question.
AUDIENCE: It's pretty
quick, but thank you
for coming, first of all.
MARK FERGUS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: When I saw your pilot,
the sci-fi geek side of me
said what technological
advancement happened
in the history of
the show that allowed
so many people and so much
material to get up into orbit?
Did you guys talk about that?
NAREN SHANKAR: Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: How do
you explain that?
What was your idea on that?
NAREN SHANKAR: It's not my idea.
It's Ty and Daniel's idea.
It's a fusion drive.
It's an efficient
fusion drive that
allows colonization
of the solar system,
and really compresses
the time it
takes to get to Mars, the
Belt, and to the planets.
That's really it.
And everything stems from it.
And they wrote a
lovely novella called
"Drive," about the
discovery of what's
called the Epstein Drive.
It's Solomon Epstein,
the guy who finds it.
And we're actually finding a
way to incorporate that story
into season 2, so
you'll actually
get a nice little explanation.
AUDIENCE: That would be very
satisfying, intellectually.
NAREN SHANKAR: I think
it will actually.
Because it's really is one of
my favorites of the novellas.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
NAREN SHANKAR: Sure.
NICK FARMER: Very, very last.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank
you very much for coming.
I love your story about coming
from a science background.
But my question is that when
you have such an enormous power
to reach the public by
your writing and putting it
on a TV series, with a
subject that is futuristic,
and of course involves a lot
of technology and science,
and given that this is
a hot topic these days,
the scientific communities,
whether film and TV series can
be a tool for enhancing public
understanding of science
and so on, for this
particular show,
have you come across the debate
whether we should have science
advisors on the team
or, or whether this
is a good place for enhancing
public understanding
of science,
how would that affect our
ratings or the type of audience
in terms of demographics?
And I haven't watched the show,
but understand that technology
is in the background,
and it's not
the main purpose of
the show, but have
you have you had
any talks about it,
or discussion about
how would that
affect the ratings,
or the audience,
and possibly the
collaboration with
the scientific communities.
MARK FERGUS: I
think audiences have
loved the-- when I say
tech in the background,
I mean the idea that we'd
be focusing on robotics
or whatever.
But what people have
been really responding
to is the science of what
happens to the human body
when you go really
fast across space?
You have the ability to do it.
The only problem is the human
body can't withstand it,
so you have to go through
a very painful drug regimen
to convince your body not to
die while you're going 20 Gs.
And then the ship
will flip halfway
through the journey
and start burning
in the opposite direction.
It will break for half
the journey as it sped up.
People are loving the
mechanics of travel,
that we're showing how
this might feasibly
get a ship of massive
mass and density
across a huge ocean of space.
And we're showing
you how it gets done,
and we're showing how
gravity, when thrust stops,
or directionality.
People are standing
in the ceiling
if their engines
over here, and we're
showing how directionality
in sci-fi is all wrong,
and when you stop thrust or
acceleration, you lose gravity.
All that stuff, people are
digging that about the show.
So I think it's we're seeing
tons of reaction in the public
to how cool is that.
So we feel like it's really
distinguishing the show rather
than becoming a
hindrance in any way.
NAREN SHANKAR: You
know what it is?
With these novels,
Ty and Daniel,
they really did a tremendous
amount of research,
and they put a lot of science
into the books already.
And so what was great
about it was they
found ways to express that
science in dramatically
interesting ways.
And so that's what
we're doing in the show.
So we don't have a
science advisor around,
because generally we
don't really need one.
I mean, I had science advisors
and technical advisors
on "CSI," but that
was a forensic show,
and that was incredibly
important for that.
But here, the situations and
the problems that come up
are already well
thought through.
We did an episode where we have
two of our characters running
across a catwalk towards
to try to escape,
and in the middle of their
run, the ship's main thrust,
main engine goes out,
and so they lose gravity.
And as they're
running, their momentum
carries them up into the air.
And the only way
they can get back
is one of the guys clips a
tether onto the other person,
flips around as they're
floating up, pushes her up,
which pushes him down, slams
him back on the catwalk.
He attaches to it, and then
that allows him to come back.
It's a beautiful illustration
of the third law,
but we don't say we're
going to teach you
about action and reaction,
but it's really interesting.
But that's how we're
doing science in the show.
There's another sequence in that
same episode, actually, where
our people are in a compartment,
and the gravity goes out again.
Thrust goes out.
And a rail gunshot comes through
the cabin instantaneously,
and basically
vaporizes a guy's head.
And so the air rushes
out of the cabin.
The guy's still bleeding
in zero gravity,
so the blood forms
this little blood head
over where his real head was.
They finally seal
the compartment
in zero G. The
gravity comes back on,
and then the blood head goes--
just splashes on the ground.
One website did a
whole calculation.
They did a mass flow calculation
on the whole thing, and said,
well we got it pretty right.
We were off by about 20%.
It's like, OK.
20% drama means 100% right.
But that's the fun
of the show, is
that you're showing science in
a dramatic way without really--
we're not teaching.
It's not school.
It's not a textbook.
What people are really
responding to, as Mark said,
is that they understand
it, because it feels real.
And they're seeing
something that
is being portrayed in a way
they really haven't before.
And I think in that
respect, it's really nice
to be able to do
that in the show,
because you're
expressing science.
You may not be teaching it, but
you're being faithful to it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NICK FARMER: Well, thank you
guys for coming and giving us
this wonderful discussion.
NAREN SHANKAR: Our pleasure.
MARK FERGUS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]